de la manière la plus performante qu'il
soit et cette intensification se
poursuivra également sur les centres que
je viens d'indiiquer jusqu'à ce que nous
puissions anéantir
daesh merci la parole est à Monsieur
Édouard
Philippe merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le ministre un
piège nous est tendu celui de
l'énervement de l'exploitation
politicienne et du réflexe partisan ce
piège nous est tendu à nous tous à nous
tous il est ancien et il est dangereux
je ne veux pas monsieur le ministre
tomber dans ce piège et je crois que
notre assemblée toute notre assemblée
sonore d'éviter alors que le monde nous
regarde nos amis comme nos ennemis de
sombrer dans les invectives et les
provocations qui sont peut-être la
marque des démocraties vigoureuses mais
qui ne sont pas la hauteur du
moment pas la hauteur des morts et au
moins aussi
grave aussi grave pas à la hauteur des
vivants vendredi soir le président de la
République a décidé de mettre en œuvre
l'état d'urgence il a pris une bonne
décision le gouvernement nous propose
aujourd'hui de proroger cet état
d'urgence de 3 mois c'est une bonne
proposition je crois même que c'est la
meilleure des réponses à l'attaque qui
nous est porté bien plus qu'une
éventuelle modification de la
Constitution et bien plus que les
nécessaires recrutements qui seront
malheureusement lents à produire leurs
effets cet état d'urgence me conduit à
vous poser questions d'abord quels sont
les objectifs précis du gouvernement
dans la mise en œuvre de cet état
d'urgence s'agit-il de prévenir de
nouveaux attentat de démanteler des
réseaux suspects de collecter du
renseignement de remonter des filières
d'agir dans les prisons deè question
quel est le niveau de menace auquel nous
devons faire face les terroristes qui
agissent sur notre sol utilisent des
armes de guerre et des explosifs faut-il
redouter l'emploi d'armes plus lourdes
encore voire d'armes non
conventionnelles 3e question enfin
Monsieur le Ministre entendez-vous dans
les jours et les semaines qui viennent
prendre des mesures pour dissoudre des
associations cultuel ou non de droit ou
de fait qui aurait apporté un soutien
direct ou indirect aux personnes
suspectées l'Assemblée nationale c'est
monsieur le ministre que vous êtes un
homme précis la représentation nationale
et les Français attend rép pr Monsieur
le Premier Ministre manuel
Vals monsieur le président ayant
présenté le texte sur l'état d'urgence
ce matin au Conseil des ministres je
vous réponds monsieur le député mais
c'est peut-être pour moi aussi
l'occasion puisque nous avons rendu
hommage aux forces de l'ordre et je veux
le faire comme chef de gouvernement
souligner tout particulièrement une
nouvelle fois l'engagement et la qualité
de l'engagement de Bernard cassneuve sa
précision son professionnalisme et son
sens de
l'État monsieur le
député vous l'avez dit la loi de 1955
prévoit que l'état d'urgence ne
peut-être prolongé que par la loi parce
que la menace et je vous réponds très
directement reste très élevée elle n'a
jamais été aussi élevée nous considérons
qu'elle est déjà depuis plusieurs mois
com pris bien sûr avant les attentats de
janvier dernier mais cette menace nous
envoyons malheureusement la
démonstration depuis vendredi est un
niveau particulièrement élevé et nous ne
devons rien écarter quand au type de
menace parce que nous faisons toujours
face donc à une situation exceptionnelle
nous prolongeons donc nous proposerons
donc au Parlement de prolonger l'état
d'urgence pour 3 mois c'est ce
qu'annoncé le président de la République
plus que jamais et c'est ça le but notre
notre objectif c'est l'efficacité et
pour être plus efficace la loi de 1955
doit être modernisé sur certains points
qui répondent d'ailleurs à vos
interrogations c'est une nécessité si
nous voulons pouvoir dans les tro
prochains mois répondre à l'urgence de
la situation à l'urgence de la menace
au-delà bien sûr de la mobilisation des
forces de l'ordre et au moment où nous
parlons après que le ministre de
l'Intérieur l' décidé la mobilisation
est absolu et total après ce qui s'est
passé ce matin cette loi de 1955 prise
dans le contexte bien spécifique de la
guerre d'Algérie n'a jamais fait l'objet
d'aucune modification substantielle elle
doit être adapté
à notre temps et adapté à la réalité des
menaces particulièrement grandes le
texte que je vous présenterai demain
proposera donc plusieurs améliorations
je pense aux assignations à résidence
qui sont un outil puissant pour
surveiller contrôler isoler les
individus radicaux et nous examinerons
bien sûr également les amendements sur
ce sujet je pense aussi au perquisition
administratives un exemple simple il n'y
avait pas d'ordinateur en 1955
aujourd'hui Internet les téléphones
portables sont les outils de
communication quotidien des terroristes
il faut être en mesure de
perquisitionner ces données une
troisième amélioration et je réponds
ainsi à votre question et je fais aussi
écho à la question de Bruno Le Maire il
y a un instant lutter très concrètement
contre le radicalisme l'extrémisme les
associations salafistes cela suppose de
s'attaquer au mosquées radical au
mosquées salafistes et donc de pouvoir
dissoudre les associations ou groupement
de fait qui le constiue nous
poursuivrons bien sûr les expulsions
d'imam étrangers qui se livrent à des
prêches insupportable par rapport aux
valeurs de la République qui représente
une véritable incitation à l'action
violente et nous espérons pouvoir
améliorer sans doute dans la réforme
constitutionnelle les moyens qui
donneront à l'état la possibilité
d'expulser encore plus rapidement ces
prêcheurs de haine enfin moderniser
l'état d'urgence c'est aussi l'adapter
aux exigences modernes en matière de
droit au recours c'est ce que nous vous
proposerons sans oublier et je sais que
vous y êtes particulièrement attaché
notamment dans cette période le rôle du
Parlement qui doit jouer son sa mission
de contrôle de la mise en œuvre de
l'état d'urgence ce chantier législatif
est extrêmement urgent il vous sera
proposé demain nous sommes convaincus
mais nous en nous en discuterons pardon
qu'il faudra le compléter par d'autres
dispositions et notamment par la réforme
constitutionnelle mais ainsi nous nous
donnons des moyens supplémentaires pour
lutter contre la violence et contre le
terrorisme merci monsieur le Premier
ministre